one of the things that strikes me about
this book is that you have to go back to
a work of literature from the 19th
century to find a woman protagonist who
is the boss who is not depicted as a
well you know how that would look in a
modern Hollywood movie right yeah
exactly that's that's what really struck
me and I keep asking people and if
anyone knows here if they can name one
other book or film indeed where a woman
is the central character who is an
employer and is not a bad guy or all
horrible bosses 2 if you can name one I
would love to hear it but that Iona read
in the book I was so stir I didn't study
it at school I know a lot of people sort
of do it at school but I hadn't so I
came to it fresh when I knew I was doing
the film and I was really struck by how
how shocking it still felt to have this
woman who is at the center of a novel
that is about her perception of what's
going on and what male characters reveal
about her and that she's breaking the
kind of rules of the society I mean
that's one of the and i'm sure you'll
ask about this but that's one of the
connections with them what what's what
sort of made sense to me eventually
about why Thomas Vinterberg doing it
which isn't an obvious choice to begin
with but when you look at his his other
films are you thinking about celebration
or the hunt and thinking about yeah
those two particularly where you've
you've got and a sort of an interest in
a very particular community and how that
community deals with someone who kind of
breaks cover within its ranks who
suddenly breaks the rules of that
community and how how they deal with it
and how that person deals with the
community which obviously happens here
just by nature of being a woman and and
suddenly running a farm she's breaking
all the taboos of her society which is
another another thing that people talk
about that sort of slightly mysterious
to them is why does she go for the
soldier what is it what's she doing with
Frank and because whatever answer well
cuz he's a sexy well in a red tunic what
he's got a big sword yeah even I would
but but
also because they're both transgresses
they're both rule breakers are bold
words in our rule breaker Gabriel's not
a rule breaker they're the two rule
breakers in the film and there's some
there's some sort of kinship there even
though obviously she realizes that she
sort of made a mistake but um yeah both
Hardy and your screenwriter David
Nicholls hint at what Boldwood has gone
through what he's experienced in his
past I think the line is I've known
disappointment before there's not a lot
of exposition in the novel and very
little in the screenplay but Thomas is
somebody who I suspect as a director
wants his actors to know a little bit
more about what the script and the novel
tells them so did you have time to work
a work on that and have conversations
about what that disappointment might
have been well yeah that was the key for
me for my character that was the key to
the whole thing for me was that you here
Bathsheba get told early on oh that's Mr
Boldwood and he he had his heart broken
once apparently there's a rumor that he
was jilted by someone and that's kind of
it and then you hear yes my character at
one point say I've had disappoint I've
known disappointment before and so when
we came to we had a week's rehearsal
which is unheard of a week's rehearsal
and what is even more unheard of is that
it was actually rehearsal it wasn't just
sitting in a room drinking coffee
showing each other your latest iPhone
talking a little bit about the scene it
was it was actual rehearsal it was
improvisation we improvised for a week
and Thomas wanted us to not only
improvise around the scenes that are in
the film but gave us the opportunity to
improvise kind of backstory things and
so because I felt that the most
important aspects of my carrot character
were all to do with what had happened in
the past and that informed everything I
just jumped on that and so I improvised
around me as a child and you know the
whole situation about when I was jilted
before and and then subsequently why I
kind of I my take on it was that this
woman broke my heart and left me and
said I don't love you anymore and left
and I because I have wealth I kind of
just retreated into this behind this was
so sort of like a citizen kane type
character just kind of
disappeared behind the walls and in fact
he's the one who really is far from the
madding crowd he just disappears from
society and and so we did improvisation
where Carrie played my sister trying to
lull me out of the place out of the
house and I and that makes me even more
kind of go no that's it I'm done so then
because the question I asked myself was
for a man who seems to have turned his
back on on society and women why does he
why does he jump on this Valentine what
what is what it what makes a man who
seems to have no interest in all that
suddenly obsessively jump on this thing
and so I felt like by the time the story
begins this is a man who already senses
he's unraveling just through having shut
himself off from everything and really
knows that maybe when Miss Valentine
comes this is may be his last chance
it's may have something healthy and when
he senses that it's going the way that
his last attempt of this goes he just I
think he spent years and years
fantasizing that he shouldn't have just
let that first woman go he should have
said I don't care if you don't love me
just don't please please don't leave me
please stay and so he's already given so
much of himself away so that as rather
than him discovering or us discovering
as an audience that he is losing all his
dignity losing his sense of self you
know his proper you know when he says if
you just if you're worried about
marrying me out of pity I don't mind
that like he's lost he's given his self
away but that mine l-cysteine that line
itself can be both you know sad but also
in some ways hopeful if you know what I
mean that there's a way to play that and
I think the way you play it is
interesting that he is not a sad sack
that maybe he recognizes who he is and
where he is oh no he's a sad sack ok
that's a flippin way of doing it but no
he I think he he is desperate and he's
not pathetic I guess is the difference
well that's what other people okay I he
died I think he really does have a sense
I mean part of what the pivotal scene
for me when I was looking at whether you
know do I want to do this because when
you're playing a character who has such
a big journey and he's not the main
character you need to make sure there is
enough material that
sustain the journey you know and and the
pivotal moment for me is that scene
where after the storm when Gabriel has
sort of saved the harvest ryllion and he
comes back to check on on how things are
and used and you haven't seen him for a
while you haven't seen him since he has
found out that Bathsheba and Troy I've
got married and when he comes and he has
a conversation with Gabriel you suddenly
we're all my god this man really is
unraveling this man has lost it and um
and that was really important to me that
not only his is he losing his his kind
of grasp on things he's also aware that
he is as well he knows he's losing his
dignity for a man who's described as
being such a dignified man at the
beginning of the film she offers the
possibility of something is opened up to
him and for his own reasons he he grasps
it and when it doesn't materialize I
meant the first conversation I ever had
with Thomas about the character I said
I've got this image of in my mind of a
like a sort of monumental monolithic
engine of like Victorian Industrial
Revolution kind of engine that has just
laying dormant for years and is covered
in rust and cobwebs and no clearly
hasn't been used for a long time and
slowly you just here and the cogs star
working and slowly it starts coming to
life and once it comes to life it just
builds up a head of steam and then it
just can't stop it's like a runaway
train and it just plows into destruction
and that's the kind of image I had for
this man what a Thomas oh I'd say yes
I'm sorry I'm Danish I know he said no
yeah he was really into that and and so
this so I yes so when this this
Valentine comes it starts this process
in him that once it gets going he can't
stop and you know he just keeps going
and I think by the towards the end of
the film my feeling was always he knows
that this isn't gonna go well he sort of
knows it's not and and yet he won't see
it he will better go to top himself yeah
so when he does shoot Troy for him to
have gone from something that seems so
hopeful he's so boyish I where you know
when he's saying
my favorite line and I always always say
this because I made it up is when he get
when he's going into the Christmas party
and there's the Christmas tree outside
and he just goes very good we're good
moorim more things I love that it's so
kind of random but he's so sort of
boyish about it and there's a party
because he's it's sort of it felt to me
like suddenly you see what he was like
before he retreat before he had his
heart broken and the associates that
we're being younger and so all that
excitement but to go from that so
quickly and that beautiful scene with
with Gabriel where where he says thank
you to Gabriel you know thank you for
looking after I know what you've done I
know how you feel about each other and
there's no sense of I've one or I don't
know something very tender and generous
about what happens there when he also I
mean he makes the most generous thing
you could he gives up his life to for
her I mean basically well he will not be
stolen from again that's that's ultim I
mean David Nicholls the the writer talks
about the idea that in the novel is a
lot more about what when you marry when
a woman marries the man she all her
property goes I mean anything she owned
as is his and so that's why Bathsheba
marrying someone is you know it means
for losing her farm it means are losing
everything and the idea of property and
all that kind of stuff and there's a big
thing to do with Boldwood we're in the
novel I think he says something I after
he shoots Troy he says something along
the lines of I'll not be stolen from
again he says all right like that and
it's you know it's to do with this is
killing himself eben yeah but I I my
take on it was much more that he's not
gonna let someone leave him again he's
not going to have someone taken away
from him again even though obviously by
shooting Troy that's it there is no hope
anyway so it's a it's sort of mess that
he's going through he's going back to
the place of trauma I believe
psychoanalyst talk about I got his
somehow the psychopomp which is a great
one is him going back to the original
trauma of his heart being broken and so
he's perceiving everything that's
happening in the story of Bathsheba
through this kind of weird sort of
kaleidoscopic broken heart